[Musik]
direkt neben der a 3 in würzburg liegen
diese gefällten bäume herum was für den
laien wie ein umweltfrevel aussieht
verkaufen die behörden als aktiven
naturschutz die kettensägen wurden
angeworfen und ein intaktes waldstück
radikal abgesägt dafür soll hier
demnächst magerrasen wachsen natur wird
für natur platt gemacht die betroffenen
anwohner sind stinksauer klar fühlt man
sich falsch weil hier ein biotop
vernichtet werden alle stimmen zu das
ist also ewig schade wie hier welcher
frevel hier betrieben wird mit der
umwelt unmöglich weil sie dürfen in
ihrem garten nix absägen in der stärke
aber die dürfen alles absegnen die haben
da gelang mit vier segen c
seit jahren wird die a3 rund um würzburg
von vier auf sechs fahrspuren ausgebaut
wo es früher streng geschützten
magerrasen gab donnert jetzt der verkehr
trüber dafür muss ein ausgleich her
doch anstatt versiegelte flächen zu
renaturieren wird hier ein kleiner wald
geopfert
dabei hat die autobahndirektion
nordbayern das gesamte gebiet mit seinen
bäumen und sträuchern als wertvollen
lebensraum bezeichnet bekloppt unter dem
aspekt dass hier die anwohner schon seit
jahrzehnten unter der autobahn leiten
ein wahnsinn dass der letzte schutz den
sie vor der autobahn haben
wahrscheinlich staub stickoxide lernen
dass er jetzt auch noch gerodet und weg
kommt alles geschehe zum wohle der natur
so die autobahndirektion nordbayern und
natürlich streng nach recht und gesetz
schriftlich heißt es der derzeitige
eingriff ist im veröffentlichten
planfeststellungsbeschluss festgelegt
die interessen der bürger werden durch
die haltung des gehalts bewuchses in den
randbereichen zum siedlungsbereich als
sichtschutz berücksichtigt eine
kümmerliche reihe bäume als sichtschutz
wo vorher ein ganzes welchen stand
völliges unverständnis bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die
verantwortlichen behörden tun so als
würden sie natur schaffen in
wirklichkeit machen sie die natur
einfach nur platt also das überlegen ich
habe baum um grashalm wachsen zu lassen
und ihre sehen
also ich finde sowas so was geht nicht
die haben nicht nachgedacht
auf der fläche soll nächstes jahr eine
ziegenherde das gras kurz halten
hoffentlich besorgt die
autobahndirektion den titel wenigstens
einen anständigen gehörschutz damit
zumindest sie nicht unter dem lärm der
autobahn leiden müssen